this video is brought to you by
playstation
peter parker and miles morales might
both identify as spider-man but the
powers given to them by their fateful
arachnid encounters aren't identical
in fact in oscar's efforts to recreate
the spider that got its feengs into
peter
they might have concocted something even
more potent
fundamentally there's a lot of
similarities between the two heroes
both are gifted with enhanced strength
resilience
agility spider sense and a challenging
work-life balance
it also seems that peter has gifted
miles with his very own web shooters
among other new gadgets so the
wonderfully intuitive web slinging
traversal from the first game
is intact and while miles has his own
line of flamboyant new aerial gymnastics
it's obvious that he's not quite as
adept as his mentor just yet
where their superpowers deviate
significantly is with miles's
bioelectricity
so not only can miles do everything
peter can he can also channel the
electricity coursing through his body
into powerful venom attacks and as we
can see from his encounter with the
underground
he's incorporated it into his fighting
techniques so his punches pack an
extra punch
the use of venom attacks add a
spectacular new visual element to
battles with miles and his
unfortunate enemies illuminated by
crackling bioelectricity as they clash
and just like peter miles uses his web
shooters and acrobatic melee moves in
tandem
but he can also trigger high impact
venom punches and body charges that send
enemies flying while incapacitating
nearby foes
there's also a tidy selection of area of
effect techniques
such as the ability to scatter enemies
with a charged ground pound
and the power to create a bioelectric
blast that levitates multiple foes
and leaves them vulnerable to mid-air
combos to keep things balanced these
moves can only be triggered when the
bioelectricity meter situated just below
the main health bar is filled
then there's the small matter of
invisibility it's not confirmed if this
is another one of miles organic powers
after all this is earth 1048 so the
rules could be a little different
but you might remember that peter was
working on a stealth suit in the first
game which he planned to create using a
fabric that could bend
sound and light waves whatever the
science behind it it's a smart way to
catch a breath
disorient the bad guys and land a
stealthy takedown
like the venom attacks use is limited by
a camouflage bar which ticks down
while it's active and has a cool down
period after use
[Music]
that's just a small taste of miles's
expandable
upgradeable range of special moves not
to mention gadgets and skills
that you'll need to take on roxanne and
the underground and keep marvel's new
york safe
[Music]
playstation